[Musique]
c'est greg guillotin regardez c'est très
très fort c'est la deuxième partie il va
nous dévoiler le concept qui l'a mis au
point pour jean-michel on s'était croisé
il ya 80 ans je faisais l'oiseau twitter
mois après tu vas cyril et il m'a dit tu
vois on a un budget qui est cinq cas par
mois
tu vois pour venir coacher les
chroniqueurs moins 5000 par la pluie
juste même là quand tu es rentrée c'est
vrai que je me suis tu toi je me suis
sentie crispé parce que c'est tout ce
que teva toutes les casseroles que tu
traînes locustes rappelle quand je
faisais l'oiseau twitter et tous que
j'étais encore tout en bas et va donc
tout ce dont le but c'est que déjà tu
arrêtes de nous parler de ta pub
volontariste qui suivront ce ballet au
genou tendinite bondues mais que les
gens se disent janvier mr inami guéri de
la tob vis-à-vis du public
là c'est important pour moi et pour ça
j'ai envie qu'on est un dispositif 360
tv web
c'est l'édition édition aujourd'hui jean
michel mr deuxième partie on commence
par le web
on compterait la chaîne youtube ça va
être une série de pastilles déclin
social ou qu'est ce qu'on voit dedans on
voit jean michel maire qui va au bois de
vincennes tu vas voir les prostituées tu
sors de la voiture monteux cadre de la
voiture que tu vallée loire et tu dis
c'est combien dl je n'allais jamais ça
j'imagine bien mais c'est pour le film
se fiant qu'à leurs attachés et tu dis
je refuse ma [ __ ] ma bataille et tu
t'arrêtes nette baisse et moi ça me fait
marrer je refais une avec un ok je
refuse ma vie tu m'as bataille et tu
t'arrêtes tu t'en vas le déjà les gens
vont se dire ok ça veut dire qu'il
refuse l'industrie du sexe et en plus je
suis sûr et certain mais alors là j'en
mets ma main à couper prennent qu'une
[ __ ] ça va faire marrer les gens tu as
eu même la [ __ ] je suis sur la
va être mort de rire quand on veut dire
c'est une caméra cachée françois une
heure pour arriver j'allais au pull pour
dire vrai le message général
moi je te propose un début de travail on
commence par le web on traite la chaîne
youtube ensuite le livre sort et tu vas
expliquer que tu fais ton mea culpa que
tu as changé
et là avec un titre fort accrocheur ses
montées pmp leur hémorroïdes et tu finis
ce livre par une phrase qui sera très
symbolique de cette oeuvre d'alain
phrase c'est finalement je n'ai été que
l'hémorroïde de tpm paix et je le
réalise mon mbp l'heure où lille ou à
leur humour il parce qu'en fait c'était
ton tmp mais tu as été l'héroïne de tout
le monde dit on tousse trimballer occupe
sur le cul tout en fait tu vois ce que
je veux dire c'est vraiment faire preuve
de cette humilité il est en est au point
de dire ouais j'ai tellement je suis
partie l'étude j'étais assez sûrs a
bluffé par le foot
bon en tout cas je veux que les gens
cela dit je vais découvrir le nouveau
jean michel hunault il faut dans sa
fouleront qu'est ce qu'on a pensé tout
ceci contre gervais en che ne paient pas
le cas ainsi s'il est payé pour la
mission salue bonne base de mémoire ou
du peuple j'ai oublié un petit truc
sangatte aziz et
jean-guy donc tout ça c'était filmé mais
tu me voyais pas arriver ce mardi 10
mars pour vol tout ça roger banque s'est
refusé à prendre tout finances à paris
[Applaudissements]